is a good way to let your friends and
family know your parents were getting
divorced because that was a Hail Mary
pass from dad to the kid
Curry their favorite
values Super Nintendo right there in
front of the TV that they ate dinner in
front of every night as a crew it's a
great place yeah it didn't look like a
divorce oh Sega was like please please
I'm so sorry she didn't mean anything to
me and I can prove that because now
everyone's playing lost Vikings [__]
that Joe defense of Sega in defense of
Sega though I never had to blow into a
tape once that was no no never ever on a
Genesis did anything ever not started no
one was playing those games